the next question is from Jenny in
Missouri my stepson moved out of the
house at 18 he refused to follow the
rules was disrespectful there were
issues with drugs
he's now 21 falling on hard times and my
husband wants him to move back in with
us we have a child together that still
lives at the home and I'm worried he'll
be a bad influence as his behaviors do
not seem to have changed he doesn't work
so we would be supporting him and we are
currently in baby step two how should we
handle this ah so what is good for the
21 year old its misbehaving he's doing
drugs and he's not working and shock of
shocks he falls on hard times well kind
of what we figured was gonna happen
wasn't it what makes him the man he
should be ten years from now when he's
31 moving him back in taking care of him
or letting him reap what he is sown what
causes him to change his behaviors for
his own good
not for your good not for my good not
even for society's good what causes him
to become a young man of character it's
probably neither of your suggestions
moving back in with no rules or no
repercussions from his misbehavior
that's called enabling and you're gonna
have a thirty one-year-old drug addict
in your basement he's gonna misbehave
and set your other kid off you're
exactly right
leaving him out there on the street
where it's cold he's not doing well he
may just end up in a real mess
so what I would tell him is this you can
come back home these are the rules
I'm not gonna charge you a dime of rent
I'm not gonna charge you anything for
food you get to live here for free
for one year during that year here's
what you will do you will get and hold
on down on the job you will attend
church with our family on Sunday morning
because that's what a people that live
under my roof do and you will be
respectful of both of us there will be
absolutely no substance in this house
because you have a problem with
substance its ruling your life you are
not ruling it and so you will not go out
and party and do substance period you're
not going to come home drunk you're not
gonna come home high and you're not
gonna bring it in the house and you're
gonna work and you're gonna save money
and you're gonna go to church yeah and
you're gonna be respectful if you can do
those things we would love to have you
come back and let's see if we can all
get a fresh start if you want to be a
little turkey then you just stay out
there with the turkey since Walker we
love you but we are not going to
participate in your crazy we're gonna
help you move away from crazy now here's
what I get here's what I think will
happen if you want my guess I have no
idea what the situation is other than
what you wrote in but my guess is that
he has not learned his lesson my guess
is is that he will not humble himself
and my guess is he's going to experience
some more hard times allowing him to do
that if he's going to continue in the
behaviors that he's in is the biggest
act of love you will ever give this
young man oh it's tough love no darling
it's just love enabling people is not
love helping them get drugs and do drugs
and helping them not work in helping
them misbehave is not love that's just
weakness that's just because you're too
weak to deal with it and love someone
well it's very difficult to do these
things it's very difficult and even if
he's out there on the street I mean
Anthony tells the story he was homeless
his dad threw him out because he was
being a butt
he threw him out he was homeless for six
months he lived in his car
even if he's out there you can keep up
with him his dad unbeknownst Anthony put
a tracker on the car so he knew where he
was and he would sit across the parking
lot he was sleeping behind a Walmart and
Anthony's dad would take his car out and
sleep across the parking lot anything he
didn't know he was there to protect him
and make sure it was okay you can keep
tabs on him and make sure he's okay
but let him experience the harm that
he's bringing to himself if he will not
humble himself and submit to your rules
of your house you cannot let him back in
the door not because you're being a you
know a turkey not because you're being
tough but because you're bringing harm
to him and it's very hard to understand
that enable errs think they're nice
people but they're actually bringing
harm to the people they love because
you're facilitating you're causing
you're helping you're subsidizing the
crazy and when you you know when
someone's misbehaving with money and you
continually give them money do you think
you're helping them helping them that's
giving a drunk a drink that's called
enabling and this is an extreme
situation with that I've never had to
face that I can't imagine the heartache
that goes with it and so it's real easy
for me to talk about in the abstract
without my heart being in my throat but
it's a real thing and I've had lots of
friends that have faced it and I've
watched friends do it right and I've
watched friends do it wrong but either
way you're real calm you're kind you're
loving you're not a harsh this is not an
act of anger on your part it's not an
act of revenge on your part it is what
is best for this 21 year old Turkey by
the way that was pretty much a 21 year
old turkey - not quite at that level I
was at least productive but rebellion I
wrote the book yeah and makes a great
talk radio host doesn't make a great kid
so but you know I mean really seriously
say you know glad people love me but I
didn't have any enablers around the
Ramseys I can tell you that if we make a
mistake it was always the other way this
is old school man
you're 18 you're out of here good luck
your rebellious or not your
you're legal what are you doing here
yeah finito stays in the nest long
enough and eventually becomes a turkey
so there you go